Hello?
I think you've got the wrong number.
Okay.
Bye!
You just keep calling me don't you?
Don’t you realize your TV is ruining
every single movie you watch?
Uh.
No.
There’s a hidden setting that’s distorting
the color, the motion, the contrast
that filmmakers want.
Wait, what’s that noise?
It's popcorn.
I only make popcorn when I’m about
to watch a movie.
Everybody warned you about it.
Tom did.
"To that end, we'd like a moment of your time
to talk about video interpolation."
The Always Sunny guys complained about it.
"I don't understand how people can't see it."
"They can't see it!"
“90% of the population does not know that
they’re watching auto motion plus.”
And your TV will still ruin your movie.
What did you say?
Check the settings.
Check them.
No, that’s not possible.
This TV is a Samsung
but every TV manufacturer has
proprietary modes
they use to market their TVs.
And they all distort the picture
in different ways.
And the dreaded motion smoothing
is just the beginning.
Have you had any personal experience
with this problem?
I distinctly remember this one experience
where I was at my parents house
and we were just sitting around and watching
some movie
and I couldn't shake the feeling
that every single time that something
on the screen was moving
there was this shadow trailing behind
people moving.
Michael Zink is a VP of Emerging and Creative
Technologies at Warner Brothers
but he’s also President of the UHD Alliance
an industry group that brings together
lots of parties
to decide, basically, how TVs should
display stuff.
So if you walk into somebody's house
are you like bound to say something
like a superhero, almost?
Yeah, you put on your cape and then you grab
the remote.
The UHD Alliance formed in 2015.
Filmmakers noticed big new problems
as HDTVs were being turned into 4K beasts
with lots of extra features.
They like to compete and show off all
the bells and whistles
and how they’re better than their competitors.
And that’s all well and good, but...
Not necessarily when you’re watching a movie.
You can see them in these short clips
from the trailers for last three
Best Cinematography winners.
I filmed them on my TV
with typical TV adjustments and
with none at all.
In "1917", the color saturations are totally
different and brightness is cranked up.
See how in "Mank", the brightness levels
are totally different?
Here’s the darkest and brightest points
in the scene, side by side.
And in Dune, you can really see
the digitally sharpened details
and cranked saturation.
These choices overwrite what the
best cinematographers and colorists wanted.
And they are baked into TVs.
Typically movies are shot or mastered
in a mastering suite
and once the movies are finished...
that's how the director wants them
to be seen.
Hey! How's it going?
Hey, what's up Phil?
I was hoping you could show me one of the
edit bays for this video.
Yea, sure, one second.
Movies are finished in dark rooms
kind of like these
probably with even fancier gear.
Hey, I'm realizing your voice sounds
a little familiar
from a call I got last night...
What do you mean?
You can manually adjust white balance
and other settings
but TV menus make it maddeningly complex.
Even the name for these baked in settings
is confusing:
“Standard picture mode” implies
basic, straightforward.
But usually, that mode is packed full
of these tweaked settings.
But the worst offender, by far, is the motion
and that’s also the hardest to show.
Here's the thing about explaining
motion smoothing.
If I were to publish this video at
60 frames a second to show you
what that looks like, you might be watching
it on YouTube at 24 frames a second
so the entire point of it would be
completely lost.
And that doesn't account for the fact that
when I do publish this video
at 24 frames a second, you might be watching
it on a "Dynamic Mode" on your TV
at 60 frames a second — artificially.
Which means it'll look totally different
and that doesn't even account for the fact
that there's going to be exporting issues
when I put this out of a software program
and compression involved with the codec
which is playing it back to you
on the internet...
It's hard.
There are some workarounds.
This ball is moving at 24 frames a second,
like this entire video.
This one is moving at 12 frames a second,
half the frames.
See the big difference in the motion?
That's as big as what your TV does
when it doubles the frames
in a 24 frames per second movie.
Here's every frame for that 24 frame
per second ball.
And here's every frame if it moved at
a typical 60 frames a second.
Do you see the huge difference
in information?
And your TV is often just making up
these frames.
You can also see what's going on
by filming TVs.
These frames are taken from a TV in
"Standard Mode"...
while these ones are totally unchanged.
This too meta for you, by the way?
We are used to seeing movies at around 24
frames a second.
Anything not that frame rate
60 frames a second, or even 30
won't have the same gaps between frames
that we're used to.
They are 24 frames per second files
but I filmed my TV at 60 frames per second.
See how in the unchanged side
there’s movement from this frame
to this frame.
Now look over here: the TV has just added
a frame in the middle
in addition to all those tweaks
to the picture.
This isn’t what we’re used to movies looking
like, for the very simple fact that
we’re used to movies only showing frames
they wanted to show us.
This frame in an example of motion smoothing.
It invents frames, which makes motion look
different from a movie.
It also creates weird, barely
perceptible artifacts
because the software just isn’t good enough.
24 frame per second videos have this
which is motion blur.
Motion smoothing invents weird
digital artifacts instead.
But we aren't stuck with it.
The UHD Alliance works to set a lot of standards
for TV
but among those standards are the relatively
new Filmmaker Mode
a TV setting with the same name, across brands
that basically turns off all the crap.
The notion behind it is, we will maintain
whatever the original frame rate is.
So if your content is in 48 or 60 or 120
or whatever that is...
that's the frame rate that TV should reproduce.
What we don't want is to add additional frames
or eliminate certain frames.
It's really making sure that whatever is in
the signal stays the way it is
and is represented on the TV
in a faithful manner.
I'm not doing this anymore.
Don't change that setting!
I have a choice!
Don't click that menu, Philip!
Don't you dare!
One of one of our colleagues at the UHDA
he always compared what
we're trying to do.
It's always this analogy of
if you go to a high end steakhouse
and you order a really expensive steak.
You want it to be brought to you the way
the chef prepares it.
You don't want the steak to arrive with a
server deciding halfway through that, hey,
let me just put a whole bunch of ketchup on
top of that because that's how I like to eat.
And that's very similar to what
these TVs are doing.
They decide for you that, hey,
this is great content,
but let me shopping it a little bit.
Let me reduce some noise.
Let me change the colors.
Oh, and by the way,
let me invent a couple of frames
in between as well.
And if a director would want to have done
that, they would have done that.
But it shouldn't be up to the television to
decide to do this.